hello and welcome
to this free webinar on metagenomics
metagenomics
is a way to study microorganisms in
their natural environment
dissecting community structures
exploring species richness
and investigating the functional roles
that these microbial communities play in
many areas related to both human health
and disease now this webinar is provided
as an
introduction to the topic of
metagenomics
and we will also discuss some of the
opportunities to continue and learn
about metagenomic data analysis
the session will be recorded and made
available
on youtube so anyone watching this will
be able to follow up
i'll also discuss several free resources
that you can have access to
after this web winner
in this webinar you will learn about the
upcoming omics logic metagenomics
program
that will be starting on august 31st
this online program
is designed to be equally rewarding to
both students
and advanced researchers and is
especially suited for
project-based learning on a flexible
schedule
the program will cover main aspects of
meta-genomic sequencing
analysis of 16s ribosomal rna
and other aspects of microbiology
research using
bioinformatics and the end of the
program participants will be conducting
independent or group projects analyzing
data from the public domain
and learning from high impact biomedical
publications
on various topics related to the
microbiome
now for those that are not familiar with
the omixlogic
data with the onyxlogic programs i want
to briefly explain what they are
all of our omics logic training programs
include
interactive online sessions
like today self-guided study materials
that we have a collection of
organized by relevant topics and these
have been carefully designed
with practical assignments in in mind so
that you
don't only learn from lectures and
presentations but you also get to apply
what you have learned to example data
sets
and then eventually to a project of your
own
and as in all of our other omix logic
programs
this onyx logic metagenomic program will
include
all three of these elements the
objective of these programs
is to allow students as early as high
school
and researchers as advanced as faculty
to learn bioinformatics or the data
analysis
aspect related to a variety of topics
and so
this program is going to be focused on
metagenomics
the program is going to start on august
31st and so
in this webinar you you'll get to see
some of the examples
that we will use in the program itself
in much greater detail
and i'll also introduce you to some of
the free resources that you can have
access to as early as today
to learn about this exciting field
so since the discovery of the microscope
humans have been learning
about microorganisms that surround us as
the resolution improved
more and more representatives of the
unseen world
have been discovered the scale of
optical resolution
can reveal details of up to one
micrometer
which is a typical size of a bacteria
but today
microscopes are tremendously powerful
allowing humans to see
smaller and smaller elements that reveal
how the world of microorganisms
function on every imaginable surface and
is actively interacting with each other
so in this image for example we can see
a super high resolution image
achieved with helium ion technology that
shows the process of bacteriophages
which
are colored in green attack e coli
bacteria which are blue
so you can see here a resolution
expanded and how these bacterial phages
are attached to these bacteria
the connection between disease and
microorganisms
has been established in the 1800s and
already towards the end of the 19th
century
laboratory methods for growing
microorganisms in a lab culture were
developed
helping characterize them with staining
these studies provided
important information about bacterial
function in isolation
however it was soon very apparent that
most microorganisms
live not in isolation but in complex
communities
and today we know that the
microorganisms
or microbiota which are communities of
microorganisms
that make up the human microbiome are
not just unicellular
organisms living alongside each other
but instead form
highly regulated structurally and
functionally
organized communities attached to
surfaces as
biofilms with interspecies
collaborations
as well as antagonisms that contribute
to ecological stability
the stability of these communities is
fascinating
as many of us probably know from trying
to battle such common skin conditions as
eczema acne and dry skin
forming distinct communities these
microorganisms
are interconnected and determined to
maintain
their community intact bacteria within a
biofilm
can communicate with each other by
producing detecting
and responding to small diffusible
signal molecules
in a process called quorum sensing which
confirms benefit for host colonization
biofilm formation defense against
competitors
and adaptation to changes in the
environment
quorum sensing activities in biofilms
are also involved
in the virulence and pathogenic
potential of bacteria
and are therefore an important factor in
understanding
and controlling bacterial infections as
they enable microorganisms and biofilms
to become more tolerant of host defenses
and antimicrobial agents so inside each
community
there is a balance of bacteria fungi
and viruses that work together to
control species abundance
and activity
the human microbiota is estimated to be
10 to the 13th
to 10 to the 14th of microbial cells
with around one to one
microbial cells to human cells ratio
previously it was thought that there is
a much greater abundance of microbial of
microorganisms
compared to human cells but since 2016
this theory has been adjusted these
numbers are actually derived from the
total bacterial cells
in the colon which is about 3.8 to 10 to
the 13th of bacteria
the or this organ harbors the densest
number of microbes however each one of
these microorganisms carries
important functional properties in genes
that contain genomic
information these properties and the
genomic information about microorganisms
have been
of a growing interest to the scientific
community
resulting in over eighty thousand
publications that have been
continuously being published in the past
decade
the majority of these studies have
focused on the intestinal microbiome as
you can see right here
but more and more studies are starting
to look at other
functional communities throughout the
human microbiome
since the 1990s microbiome studies were
significantly advanced through such
major initiatives as the metagenomics of
the human intestinal tract
and the subsequent human microbiome
project
these were huge studies that are ongoing
and that
made it possible that have been made
possible through the advances in
metagenomic sequencing
as a result we now know that there are
distinct communities that can
characterize skin
lung gut and even brain microbiota
today we know that the endogenous human
microbial communities contribute to
critical
metabolic physiological immunological
and even psychological functions
including
differentiation and maturing of the host
mucosa and its immune system
food digestion and nutrition energy
generation
metabolic regulation and control of fat
storage
processing and detoxification of
environmental chemicals
maintenance of skin and mucosa barrier
function
development and regulation of the immune
system and fine
tuning of its reaction pattern which is
the balance between pro-inflammatory and
anti-inflammatory processes prevention
of invasion and growth of
disease-promoting microorganisms
and many more importantly
these studies and questions being
answered about the microbiome
have been as a result of important omix
technologies
these include sequencing technologies
sequencing of the dna
and the rna as well as mass spectroscopy
meta-proteomics and metabolomics
together these studies form a multi-omic
approach which is something that allows
us to study
the omic data about a community and find
associations between different features
in distinct omics data types so in this
program
we will focus on one of these omics data
types
which is metagenomics so
unlike proteomics genomics and
transcriptomics which all focus
on the whole of a single organism
organisms
in the microbiome live in communities
and
interact with each other and so when we
study them
we want to study the community and the
most
dominant and functional members of that
community
so the metagenomics approach is an
approach to study
genetic materials sampled directly from
an environment
which allows the study of communities of
organisms directly in their natural
environment
and bypasses the need for isolation and
lab
cultivation however metagenomics
sequencing of microbiome communities
and detailed studies of individual
members of that community
are typically working together hand in
hand
for example metagenomic sequencing can
be applied to environmental culture free
sequencing
to study populations where we are
looking
at culture-free sequencing reads
using databases to annotate operational
taxonomic units
and study taxonomic classification
in the case of culture-based sequencing
reads
we are typically using reference genomes
and assembly to study genomic
classification by
understanding how the specific pre
members of the community that we're
interested in are different from other
known members
and how might they be related to each
other
in the case of 16s metagenomic
sequencing
we can use specific genes for example
the ribosomal
16s rna gene to understand
the relationship of different species at
a
at different taxonomic levels what is
important about this approach is that
the 16s
gene is short enough to fit in
for in a full in the is full sequence
in a typical paired and read for meta
genomic sequencing
the and ribosomal rna gene itself is
about
1500 base pairs long and when it is
sequenced
typically only one portion of that gene
a hyper variable portion of that gene is
sequenced
to understand how it can represent the
complexity and the relationship of the
community
based on the presence and
richness of particular species
this is done by relying on what's called
operational taxonomic units
which are basically a definition
of a particular type of
group of sequences that relate to
closely related individuals
those could be organized by hierarchical
clustering
algorithms and annotated
using specific databases some of these
databases include
the silva database which contains
taxonomic information for the domains of
bacteria
archaea and eukarya which is based
primarily on phylogenys
for small subunit ribosomal rnas
the taxonomic rank information for
archaean bacteria
is obtained from virgi's taxonomic
outlines
but there are other databases as well
these include the ribosomal database
project or rdp
as well as the green genes taxonomy
it has been studied that the silva
database provides some of the most
up-to-date and validated information
as a result of this indentation we can
organize
different communities in terms of their
biological classification revealing the
composition of distinct communities
that could be specific to different
organs
or compared between different conditions
but the 16s ribosomal rna allows us to
study
only the bacteria however when we talk
about the microbiome
that also includes the viral
the virum is one part of the microbiome
which constitutes all of the organisms
that inhabit us
including bacterial and or kale
organisms as well as the microbiome
and other members of the male fauna such
as protists and metazoans
studies of the birom are in their
infancy because it has only recently
become
possible to see the virum in large
sequence data
using bioinformatic tools that can
detect relationships between viruses
despite extreme nucleotide sequence
diversity
the size of the mammalian viral is
actually not known
although our own cells are outnumbered
about ten fold by a bacterial microbiome
the number of viruses may be 10-fold
higher still
human feces alone contain about 108
viruses per gram additionally the
mammalian viral is continuously updated
through rapid evolution of viruses
and through exposure to viruses in the
environment or in other mammals
so the microbiome actually helps contain
the diversity of the viral forming a
protective layer
between our immune system and the
environment that we're in to study the
viral
additional types of sequencing could be
methods could be used
specific libraries can help amplify the
amount of genomic information
that we can extract from these
microbiota
and amplify them enough so that we can
map them to reference genomes assemble
them into novel genomes
and discover how they evolve based on
specific conditions or samples involving
diseases
so we know viruses causing infectious
disease
diseases that are typically acute these
include
flu dengue ebola and copen19
however many of these viruses also cause
chronic diseases that sustain continuous
inflammation
and lead to diseases even as complicated
as
cancer some of the commonly known
viruses that are associated with
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
cases
of cancers every year
include the abstain bar virus human
papillomavirus
and hepatitis b and c so in this program
what we'll do
is we will use practical examples
from the world of the microbiome
virum as well as individual species
that play major roles in human health
and disease one of the projects that
we'll look at
is called the american gut
this is a project that is a
a portion of the human microbiome
project
and it relies on citizen science
which means that every single one of us
can contribute a sample
from this from our saliva
provided to them and they will do the
sequencing and
find how our sample compares to other
known samples from
a variety of people that also answer
self survey questions for example
your diet your genetic conditions your
ethnic background
age and others we will also look
at specific types of examples that help
us understand the function
of microbiome in conditions
that are non-intuitive for example
the gut brain axis might show
that there is a relationship between the
microbiome
and behavior so
in this example we'll take a look at how
researchers were trying to look at the
specific function of the microbiome the
gut microbiome
irrespective of the diet itself
that had an impact on anxiety
to study many of these types of data
sets we will rely
on bioinformatics so when we speak about
bioinformatics
that includes taking sequencing data and
analyzing this data to understand the
relationship
between sequence variation
and particular phenotypes that we can
study
collecting other types of data to do
that
we will rely on an intuitive platform
called the t bioinfo platform on this
platform
we have specific pipelines that have
been designed
to make such studies intuitive and quick
so let me show you an example
here i will just show you a brief
example of how you can
understand a complicated bioinformatics
pipeline
that actually produces organized
information
and visualization about a particular
data set
so i will go here quickly to the
metagenomics
microbiome area and you can see that i
have a couple of sections related to
this one of them
is related to whole metagenomic
sequencing
okay sorry please when you're joining uh
make sure that your microphone is muted
so what we'll do is we'll first
understand the logic of analysis
in this case we're dealing with 16s
ribosomal rna
which is sequencing of hypervariable
regions
in the 16s ribosomal rna gene
after that we will apply the data to
bioinformatics workflow
and understand each step that helps us
eliminate the noise and create clusters
of sequences
called operational taxonomic units
these operational taxonomic units could
be then annotated
based on their relationship
and based on known operational taxonomic
units
that will reveal the complexity and the
relationships
between different samples in our study
to visualize we will use a popular
package called
philoseek that allows us to build
phylogenetic trees
and understand species diversity and
richness
in comparing multiple types of samples
so let's take a look at some of the
outputs that we will get
one of the outputs is going to be a
table of abundance
for individual otus since they were
prepared based on all of the samples in
our data
we can now select specific samples in
the data
associated with a condition and compare
them between each other
so once they are annotated you will see
that
specific level of information at the
species genus family
and order and class could help reveal
how different types of diets or
microbiomes that were
results of these diets could show
differences between these two conditions
by providing such examples we will
understand the
inputs the logic and the outputs of
complex bioinformatics pipelines
and as a result of this program once
that logic is clear
you will think about how can i apply the
same types of approaches
to study some other examples that might
be relevant to whatever you're
interested in
so what kinds of questions or what kinds
of projects
could be studied using such analysis
in many cases we can compare conditions
for example a healthy
versus disease but you can do even more
by understanding how these functional uh
how these studies characterize the
function of specific bacteria
you can study a variety of different
data sets
related to the impact of antibiotics
the relationship between microbiome and
different treatments
understanding how to select specific
interventions and many discoveries
that were related to microbiome changes
associated with conditions such as
alzheimer's disease and
others especially in treatment selection
we now know that the microbiome has
a specific impact on our ability to
process
different types of treatments for cancer
and even find specific variations
in the microbiome that help predict drug
response
so by providing such examples you will
be able to apply
different skills related to
bioinformatic data analysis
and integration of different types of
omics data
to understand how to find
microbial signatures how to understand
functional species richness studies
and understand how to
find and extract data sets
from these public repositories for your
future studies
so what we'll do in the program itself
in the onyx logic metagenomic program
is we will spend two weeks learning
about
different types of sequencing techniques
analysis
steps like mapping on databases data
visualization and processing
and understanding how to apply pipelines
bioinformatic pipelines
that produce different types of outputs
in the second week
we will start seeing different examples
project examples like the american gut
and the human microbiome the diet
and anxiety relationship as an example
with
the different types of disease studies
and other research examples that are
based on treatment variation
and intervention
an important part of this program is to
reveal
how bioinformatics can help us explore
big data from different types of omics
and find associations between omic
features
and clinical phenotypes and when we do
this in the context of the microbiome
we will look at the relationship between
cellular omics or the host
as well as the microbiome and the viral
to understand how different types of
clinical
conditions develop and could be
intervened
as a result you will have time after
these two weeks
to develop your own bioinformatic
project
and that will be presented for expert
feedback
and community feedback so that you will
understand
how you can demonstrate the skills that
you have acquired
and translate that into an impactful
project that demonstrates both your
research capabilities
ability to apply bioinformatic analysis
and develop specific visualizations and
presentations that help you communicate
both your skill and the research
discoveries that you have made
now an important objective for us in the
omics logic programs is to provide a
clear perspective
on how bioinformatics machine learning
and artificial intelligence is used in
research
clinical and industry applications and
what we'll do is we'll
do this by quickly providing with access
to industry standard tools and enabling
infrastructure
exposing you to a variety of different
analysis
approaches that clarify the logic in
application to real data sets and
provide you with some examples
with a variety of projects where you can
see how variation
in the settings of specific parameters
can play a major role
in the output from these different
studies
as a result you will understand how
different types of sequencing
technologies
and different experimental designs
could be translated into a step-by-step
bioinformatic analysis pipeline and
how different types of outputs could be
interpreted from a biological
or clinical standpoint so in our team
our mentor team in the program will be
able to assess your progress at every
stage of this
developing program and provide you with
some feedback
on where you might apply specific types
of logic
and improve your understanding so that
you can become
more effective using bioinformatics in
this case in application
to metagenomic data now there's a
question here from christina
who is asking will there be another
offering for this program later this
year
so we have a whole yearly schedule of
different types of programs that we do
and we'll be able to share that
information with all of those that are
interested
an important part of this is that we are
going to rely
on public domain data sets so we'll
actually
do a whole session on how to find
appropriate types of data how to
understand
which data sets are going to be
applicable for
different types of analyses and we'll do
a hands-on downloading and exploring
different types of data sets
and understanding what they might be
useful for
in the context of microbiome and
metagenomic studies
many of our previous participants have
been able to demonstrate
what they have learned in the context of
research projects
and presentations at conferences
where they were able to provide an
insight into a particular area related
to their research or to their study
including high school students that have
used this as an opportunity to develop
research projects in the context of
their application
for colleges and further studies that
they were interested in
so first of all we will start by doing a
little bit of an introduction and an
overview and the program will start on
august 31st
and this is uh just a few sessions that
we plan to have
and before i go through these let me
show you
where you can find all of this
information as i am speaking about this
so if you're interested in learning
about metagenomics and microbiome
i'm just going to explain a little bit
about how
we will structure this program and what
are the different resources that you
will have access to
in this program
so on august 31st we will start
the sessions the sessions will typically
happen between
10 and 11 30 a.m cest central
standard time um and what we'll do
is we'll start with the review of the
program objectives the different topics
that we
will cover and the different resources
that you will get access to in the
context of this program
we will then talk about metagenomics
and here i want to highlight that there
is a free course that you can already
take
on an introduction to metagenomics and
introduction to violent informatics for
those of you that are interested
in just getting started you will find
those
on the same website edu that t fio.info
so in the introduction to next
generation sequencing for metagenomics
we will talk about
how next generation sequencing
technology could be used to study whole
genomes
and study microbiome
we will then talk about how the
microbiome
is a functional bacterial community and
we'll do this using
an example from the human microbiome
study so here we'll discuss different
types of databases like silver green
genes and ncbi
and talk about what are these
hypervariable regions
and how are they used to produce
operational taxonomic units
we'll then talk about the variability
and composition
ultimately we would like to compare
different communities to each other how
so how can you do that
knowing that this is going to be
composed
of different types of units that
represent
hypervariable regions so we'll talk
about methods
like shannon diversity and species
richness
and especially focus on different
pipelines that are designed
to eliminate a lot of the noise that
comes as a result of these specific
sequencing technologies
then we'll transition to our hands-on
project sessions in these sessions
we'll use projects like the american gut
and other examples and also discuss how
you can find
some of these freely accessible public
domain data sets
and apply the same analysis tools that
we've discussed in week one
to the different data sets to ask
specific questions
from data then we'll to look
at this relationship between microbiome
variation
that can be established in the early
years of life
with long-term effects on
subtle conditions for example these
could be chronic diseases
or they could be subtle conditions like
anxiety
we'll also talk about how to develop a
metagenomic project so if you're
interested in another area for example
you might be interested
in questions like the association
between
microbiome variation and diet
or the impact of microbiome variation
on disease or tolerance to different
treatments
we'll talk about how to find data how to
upload the data to the cloud-based
systems that we will provide you in the
context
of this program how to then prepare your
project to focus on a particular
question
and follow specific techniques that
allow you to record
every step of your analysis to make the
data analysis reproducible
and presentable in the context of a
research study
what's important is that at the end you
will be able to
submit your project for evaluation and
when you submit that project for
evaluation
we will focus on the best projects from
the whole
program that will get feedback from
experts in our network these experts
come from
different academic projects or programs
sorry
and from industry experience so they
will be able to provide you with
both feedback on the project itself but
also
answer any kinds of questions that you
might have about
the future using bioinformatics in
application to metagenomic data
sequencing
so let's take a look at some of these
resources that we've been mentioning
as i said there's already uh there is
a platform that you will get access to
for doing your metagenomic analysis
and this platform provides different
levels of access you can start from
demo which is what i just did now and i
showed you
an example of a specific project and the
analysis
inputs and outputs as well as the logic
after you complete several exercises in
the demo version of the platform
you'll be able to upload specific data
sets that we will provide you with
that are annotated and already
understood by our team
so that you can make sure that your
analysis is reproducible
after that if you continue and develop a
project of your own
you'll be able to go to ncbi
and start researching different
accessible microbiome
data sets understanding
what types of data sets are out there
how to find
the necessary types of data for the
analysis that you're planning
and understand different types of
sequencing techniques
that are going to be possible to use
in the context of your research program
of your research projects are
in the same time you will be given
specific assignments
if you look at the syllabus you'll see
that for each one of our sessions
we will have specific coursework that
you have to complete
inside this coursework you will be able
to do
practical assignments based on a
particular project
so by completing those assignments
you'll actually run some analysis
and see the result that you will have to
interpret from a biological or a
clinical
standpoint now throughout the whole
process
we will have a lot of support available
to you
when you are facing some technical
challenge or you have a question that
you need
clarification with about methods or data
sets
we will be interacting with you using a
forum
and at the end of this process you will
have to submit
a project where you identify a specific
problem statement and develop
a an analysis plan for a particular
data set from the public domain so you
can see here some examples
and we'll be providing with examples of
previous participants of these programs
where you can learn about how they have
been able to develop
very interesting projects on a variety
of topics
from different types of disease studies
to an understanding at the basic
mechanistic level
how some of these pathogens and
bacteria function
so this is where you would go to
complete your registration
uh these are already in the chat pasted
some links
for pre-registration so the way that the
process works
is you first submit your information
about your current
educational background your interest
your level of familiarity with
bioinformatics
we review that information and we
provide with different types of
suggestions for you to continue on to
complete your registration once you
complete your registration
you start getting access to the
resources that will be included in the
program
i have to note that these resources
might take some time
for you to complete so if you have time
before the program starts on august 31st
you can already get started with some of
the introductory materials and be caught
up for the program itself
you will also be able to get access to a
whole community of participants we have
several thousand participants on the
platform
that all work through similar course
work and
similar types of analyses and then we
will facilitate
interaction between the participants so
that
you can potentially organize a group
project together with
others and learn from others that have
more experience
so i will welcome all of you to join us
for this omix logic metagenomic program
again the microbiome itself is a
fascinating topic that provides
many opportunities for research and
study
you will be able to understand both the
aspects of
biological and clinical importance of
the microbiome
and the different members of the
metagenomic community or the
microbiota you will also get access to
bioinformatics tools and training
that will give you some skills to
develop an independent project
and apply your bioinformatics
understanding
to different types of public domain data
sets
now at the end of this presentation i
just also want to mention
that you can already connect with us and
our team on social media
you can do this by joining our group on
linkedin
where there's a community of over 500
students researchers and industry
professionals
that are all engaged in bioinformatics
machine learning
and different types of data science and
you can
learn by interacting there with the
members of this professional community
we also have a large group of
participants of previous programs
on our facebook group and that is called
learning biomedical informatics so
joining that
also will give you access to some of the
recurring
program information where you can keep
up to date on upcoming programs
and these programs include much more
than metagenomics
we have yearly a yearly schedule of
programs related to genomics
transcriptomics
metagenomics epigenomics data science
oncology precision medicine and
infectious diseases so there's really a
variety of topics that you can explore
if you go to our website you will find
that we have
we have some several upcoming programs
that are highlighted
and also a lot of different resources
such as courses projects specialization
tracks and even coding
skills that you can gain by practicing
different
types of data science techniques and
machine learning
so we're excited to welcome you and i
will
open this for questions also if any one
of you has any questions i would be
happy to answer those now
hi this is shreya uh could you
it was a great presentation earlier um
could you
tell me where exactly could could i find
out the information about
the different data science um
um courses or or the information where i
could
get some information about data sciences
yes would be happy tune thank you
we have a
code.onyxlogic.com
which is a place where once you have
registered on the edu site
with the same login information you can
practice all kinds of data science
related
exercises in both r and python
and learn about how to apply these
different types of
methods to different omics type data
so code omixlogic.com
but you do have to be registered on this
educational portal first for your
account to be confirmed
good thank you thank you
so again for all of you that are joining
for the first time
registration here is free all you have
to do
is right here you will see
a place where you have to provide your
email and um
password you can also register using
different types of social media
platforms and what's important here is
that you actually get to build your
profile starting from free basic courses
so you don't have to pay anything to
actually
start your bioinformatics training
here you will go to login or
register and you have a
variety of options here so you provide
your
first last name and register here
i'll just log back in and show you a
couple of
things about your profile
so once you register and have an account
on this educational site
you can choose between different types
of access
so there are many courses that are free
including introduction to bioinformatics
include introduction to metagenomics and
others
you'll be able to find them here under
the courses
and you will start building your profile
this profile includes a point system
that allows you to
generate points for different for
completing
different types of courses
doing independent projects and
participating in different programs on
different topics
all of these will then be displayed on
your main profile so let me give you
a different example that's not me
so here's an example of a participant
from a previous program
that was able to complete a full program
and also develop an independent project
this kind of this kind of program
actually offers you um a full profile
with a certificate from the latest
program that you have completed and you
can share that
um obviously on uh your cv
or linkedin and as you uh
complete different courses there is an
interaction so you do
submit quizzes and different types of
assignments and you get graded on those
assignments you actually get feedback
if you face some challenges you'll be
able to see that
our previous participants had provided
important feedback
about how this program is different from
your typical online course
so i invite you to explore our blog
and also look at this blog on one
specific article
that i think summarizes a lot of the
different ways that this program
is different from your other typical
programs
on bioinformatics so importantly this is
not
a program where you just look at
lectures
and go through some videos there is
an interactive session where all of your
questions are answered
and there is going to be a feedback
that you get for your personal progress
in the program
okay so there's a question
the best courses for beginners i would
recommend the free courses like
introduction to bioinformatics and other
introductory courses
however in the program the program is
designed for high school students
all the way to faculty the interesting
thing is that
you get to participate in sessions and
make decisions on your next steps
so you can again use the
asynchronous courses that cover a
variety of different topics
join the program sessions to get answers
to your questions
and focus on a particular domain and
also then decide whether you are
interested in developing an independent
research project or not and so to answer
christina's question here as well
you can either purchase courses
individually or select a membership
option that will allow us to take course
offerings in parallel
exactly so as a part of your program
you will have access to particular types
of courses
if you are interested in taking other
courses not related to metagenomics you
can also get access to those through our
basic
membership which starts at ten dollars a
month for premium courses
and for the courses that are free
obviously you only need to be registered
now throughout the year we have
different types of training programs
that are focused on different types of
omics data
these include genomics transcriptomics
epigenomics metagenomics data science
oncology precision medicine infectious
diseases
and others and so you also can get an
unlimited membership that gives you
access to both
projects and all of the sessions
throughout the year
importantly many of the research users
that we have
are leveraging our cloud-based
infrastructure to conduct their own
independent bioinformatics research
and in those they utilize a research
account that research account
also gives you access to the cloud-based
tools as well as the sessions that we
have for all of our programs
and access to asynchronous courses if
you're interested in learning about
something specific
we also have a series of projects these
are examples
that provide you with a springboard into
a particular type of application
of data science methods and different
types of sequencing data
that you can explore here on
agriculture different medical topics
alzheimer's or different
neurodegenerative diseases
and others
okay so again the program is going to
start on august 31st
uh you still have until tomorrow to take
advantage of the 30
discount to complete your registration
for the metagenomic
omics logic metagenomics program once
you complete that registration or even
before you complete that registration
you can start accessing courses and
projects are available here
how will the feedback help sessions work
for this meta genomics course
so if you're interested in developing
your own research project
you go through the basic training and
start thinking about
what type of a data set and what
question you would like to answer with
that data set
so if you want to take a let's say the
impact of
microbiome transplant from fecal
transplants the impact on
let's say obesity you can find a data
set like that on ncbi
and then learn in the courses and the
interactive sessions
how to actually take the data set apply
a specific analysis
and interpret the results at some point
you will submit your proposal
so at that point you'll get to present
your proposal to
both the participants of the program and
the trainers in the program
and get feedback they will provide you
with written feedback
and you will be able to start working on
your project
at the end when you have completed your
project you will submit a presentation
either powerpoint presentation or a
video
and if it is one of the top 10 projects
you will actually get feedback from an
expert that could be an industry expert
or an academic expert
in bioinformatics that will provide you
with some feedback on what you have done
so shreya hopefully that answers your
question
another question could you please
suggest the best course for plant
biologists
so depending on your question i think we
have a number of projects like the crop
draw drought stress um
but to be completely honest and
transparent
i think that the majority of the courses
are a little bit more on the biomedical
side
if you're interested in plant-specific
projects that are related to the
microbiome
we will discuss the particular types of
sequencing
and a few different examples but you're
free to start working on a
microbiome to plant related
questions and we have we do have
examples of that that we could leverage
in the program as well
and that's actually what makes this
program i think more flexible
you could actually look at a variety of
different
questions and data sets starting from
the very beginning of the program
okay the question is there any tool that
can be used for
interpreting the results so typically
that will include
some analytical tools and i showed some
analytical tools that we will leverage
here in this example that allow us to
find differences in composition
and allow us to understand the
relationship between different species
in terms of their abundance or richness
once you have that you also rely on
databases
so for example with 16s ribosomal rna
sequencing
we do rely on different databases for
annotation ultimately your goal is to
understand the relationship between the
statistical analysis
and the biological interpretation that
you can develop
for specific features so we will go
through some of those steps
during this program as well
thank you so much yep thank you for
joining um
what is the weekly time commitment for
this course okay yeah did you have a
question bellow
yes i do i have a question now my
beginner who is interested to learn
my cover home sequencing uh
could you please suggest a blessed
platform to learn a
programming language i mean maybe
someone wants to learn how
to program a language do you have any
platform
where someone can learn that yes so as
i already mentioned we have a whole set
of exercises that are
designed around data science topics
in both r and python so you can explore
some of those
after you create an account on the
educational portal
you can actually explore some of those
right here and
you know again what we start with
is we start with the logic of analysis
but then also in many cases we provide
you with
pieces of code that you can start
learning how to modify
to apply to a particular data set of
your interest
okay thank you yeah thank you yes
there's another question from serene
srinivasan
okay um
what is the weekly time commitment so
you can
look at the syllabus it depends on
whether you would like to have just the
training sessions which is one option
so for example you it's an hour and a
half
interactive session that will be
recorded and all stored in a single
location so you could review all of the
sessions at any time
but you can see that that is two weeks
three sessions per week so you can see
um august 31st september 2nd
and september 4th that's week one and
then september 7th
september 9th and september 11th that's
week two
and then we transition into a project
so you have a project how to find the
data
how to structure your project how to
start your
translate your idea into an analysis
step-by-step analysis
and then after you have some time to
work on your project
and there will be also a review session
you might work
by yourself or together with a group and
then at the end
you get feedback from somebody else now
this second portion about an independent
project
is not compulsory you can get a
certificate of participation just after
completing the two-week training
which in total will be three
one and a half hour sessions in one week
and three one and a half hour sessions
in second week so
in a total of 10 hours you can complete
the whole program
now as you can see for each one of these
sessions there are some additional
resources
and the minimum courses are introduction
to metagenomics metagenomics one and
metagenomics two
so there are three courses you can
complete each course
in about a couple of hours but they do
include some practical assignments that
will take a little bit more time
so i think that a good estimate is about
20 hours for the whole program
is a good estimate for what you would
need
and this is over the course of two to
three weeks
but you will have access to all of these
for about a month
so you can actually spread it out
throughout the whole month
can we get access to one of the best
proposals yes i believe that
um biebs have already mentioned that she
will share that with you
um but i will also um
share that now so you could all take a
look
so actually we have a youtube channel um
thank you bieber so there's a link
we actually have a youtube channel where
you can find
a lot of these presentations for
different students
here's an example of a project related
to
related to different topics so here's a
couple of
presentations and on that link that uh
beeps are provided there some more
you will get two weeks to complete your
project so from the
um set from the end of second week
all the way to the um to october
1st or october 2nd
you will have time to work on your
independent project
october 2nd
okay great so for any additional
questions please feel free to reach out
to us
marketing at pine dot bio is the email
address would be so you could please put
that on the chat as well
this recording is going to be available
on youtube
after this
about a project is it possible to do a
group project of a friend
or a colleague of mine is interested yes
you have to be participants
of the program itself to get the
feedback
and get evaluated if you would like to
do that but within the program
you will have a number of different
opportunities to interact with others
and we have
many examples where people have worked
together to
produce group projects so i'll just give
you
an example of a group project
that you can see
so you can see an example of three
participants working together
and developing a project together again
thank you everyone
for joining today if you would like to
stay in touch you can
email us to marketing at pine.bio
and for those of you interested in
joining the program
we're going to be starting on august
31st so we're excited and ready to see
you there
you